[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voir les enfants patrons beaucoup de
petits amis n'écoute pas comme il le
faudrait
l'automne comme seul mon petit doigt me
le dit mais c'est normal nounours voyons
ce sont les vacances ils sont distraits
ils ont envie de jouer de partir à la
mer à la campagne
moi j'irais bien faire un petit tour à
la montagne ma chère soeur emilie la mlv
ne manque pas trop nous irons nounours
c'est rami vive le bac au bond les sols
liée aux propos peu
mon blog 9 tiens c'était encore de la
place mais cette fille salma ta valise
la cuisse elle s'affaire toujours en
vacances tu as raison cornichons des
valises vous partez en vacances bien
terne à la rampe et actes c'est
tellement agréable les vacances ou qui
servent à
ses cornichons j'ai encore du chou oui
j'ai moi j'étais invité dans sa roulotte
c'est par à vienne me chercher on va
faire des voyages en roulotte avec
juliette armée
[Musique]
et avec dada
je suis content de le revoir celui là
mais bien les enfants je vous ferai
peut-être la surprise d'aller vous dire
un petit bonjour
chicala
que ce million c'est mumbai en inde il
retrouve la
[Musique]
[Rires]
solution
c'est le mien il est trop petit pour toi
allons-nous nous reçoit résonna ils sont
pas achalés quand on part en vacances
cheuvreux ce tout le monde et les wagons
17il show des enfants chez nous avant de
partir au vin comme l'eau qui chantent
vive les vacances plus de pénitence à
les cahiers au feu les métros
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
millions les enfants je vous souhaite de
bonnes vacances
non chez ma soeur des millions
de fans notre part je n'y manquerai pas
musher petit neveu j'ai hâte de les
revoir
allons les enfants ou lui vend non crime
nous saleh l'ours repose toi viens
nous voir mes chers petits
rois je tends
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
à bientôt les enfants passer de bonnes
vacances en route trop qu'est ce que tu
as nounours tu es triste un peu pas trop
assez longue séparation
ils vont me manquer seul enfant à moi
aussi mon nounours
allons en août pour voir tous nos petits
écrans aux amis aux bientôt
[Musique]
oh
e
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]